this is a production of cornell
university
thank you rebecca for that introduction
and thank you everyone for joining this
afternoon uh like rebecca said i'm going
to be talking about a topic that maybe
a lot of you are not familiar with but
that's a personal and professional
passion of mine
how do you integrate gender issues
specifically and social difference
into plant breeding programs so brief
outline i'll start with some
slides on conceptual clarity for the
first third of my talk that's just to
kind of level the playing field so as
i'm talking about some concepts
that you're all at least familiar with
what i mean the second third of the talk
will looking at how the issue of
integrating gender and social difference
into plant breeding has been framed more
recently
and the last third we'll really talk
about a research case study from nextgen
cassava and how practically we've
approached this question
and implementation
so conceptual clarity is very important
because as
you know if you're speaking two
different languages and a lot of this
work is very interdisciplinary
that can have repercussions on
misunderstandings or or
kind of not being able to move forward
together
the next few slides i'm going to borrow
heavily from a program
that i'm involved as a co-pi that's
called
great and this is a gender training
program for agricultural researchers
in sub-saharan africa and it's a joint
certification between macquarie
university and cornell university so i'm
borrowing a lot from those slides for
this first third
and just a quick shout out to margaret
mangani here in the in my co-pi in the
picture here and her fantastic training
team at macada
for producing some of this material and
some familiar faces margaret has guests
lectured with us as has eva who was one
of the co-presenters in the series a few
weeks back
so there's more information on the
website if you're interested
so the first thing i just first
disclaimer perhaps to mention
is that everything i'm going to talk
about from here on out
is really the the treatment of gender
and agricultural research agricultural
development
is is very narrow in its definition so
we talk about women versus men or we
talk about female versus male
but we don't really address it in the
complexity that you see in in feminist
gender and sexuality studies
where you look at the multiple layers of
gender identity expression and sexual
orientation
so that's not a choice on my part but
the fact that a lot of the literature
and a lot of the work
historically has really treated gender
identity to be
binary and there's a lot problematic
with that and there are glimmers of hope
and a bit of research going on in
different areas but by and large it has
remained very binary
so a lot of the times the first thing we
start with is difference between sex and
gender and i'll just spend a few minutes
on this sex
is biologically defined and acquired at
birth
males and females are defined
independently of one another and the
definition is mostly the same around the
world
whereas gender is completely socially
defined it's culturally learned
differences between what it means to be
a man or where it means to be a woman
the gender is really defined as a
relational concept socially constructed
and relational what that means is what
it means to be a man
is defined in relation to what it means
to be a woman and these relationships
are usually relationships of power
and the definition of what it means to
be a man or what it means to be a woman
vary greatly across geographies but also
across time so it's not a static concept
it changes continuously
and that'll become a little bit clearer
why we're making this distinction later
on
a few more concepts as a glossary gender
roles i'll talk about this a little bit
are the behaviors tasks and
responsibility that are considered
appropriate for men and women
and these are social cultural norms so
they're defined by
social social society and culture and
for example
of this could be in agriculture women
weed where men prepare land so these are
the roles of
of men and women across cultural value
chains for different
crops gender relations are the social
relationships of power between men and
women
they're really shaped again by social
beliefs and institutions
and you see this a lot in agriculture
research in the way that husbands are by
default defined as heads of households
and that they are the decision makers
for the household that's a relationship
of power between a husband and a wife
gender stereotypes are kind of beliefs
about certain groups or types of
individuals that are based not on
evidence but on
assumptions and this is really important
for example a lot of times you'll see
stereotypes around men's or women's
crops certain men's or crops or women's
crops what does that mean
or that women are too weak to operate
machinery for example or
they can't engage in certain activities
in agriculture and that's not really
based on evidence but really
socially constructed norms
this is a really important concept
intersectionality and you may have seen
this
of late uh mentioned more recently
this uh concept emerged by kimberly
crenshaw to really define the double
whammy of sexism and racism and how
those two coming together excluded black
women specifically from feminist
movements
so it's really grown since that initial
definition to
to raise awareness around there is no
universal women
or men for example as we're talking
about men and women in agricultural
research
all women and men do not share the same
experiences so you can't
generalize and there's multitudes of
other identities that over
overlap and interact with gender to to
really define
those individuals lived experiences
and what this mean again for agriculture
research is not all women who may also
be farmers benefit from the same
solutions and who they are
and where they live in their lived
experiences will really impact how
they're benefiting
from different interventions
and another concept that i'll talk about
repeatedly is interdisciplinarity and
most of you know what this means but i
just want to point one thing out that is
in in the more objective sciences that
that we engage in
we seek truths and there are singular
ways of knowing and truths that we
look for whereas in the social sciences
it's generally accepted that as an
individual researcher you have a
position
and that you should be open and and
forward with that position
and lay that forward before you even
make your claims
and that the claims that you make are
truth claims not absolute truths and
that there
may be multiple ways of knowing
and what that means is i think is really
important for us to realize is as we all
personally carry these positions norms
stereotypes biases and beliefs
these really play into everything that
we do the research topics we choose the
questions we ask our approaches the
teams that we put together and actually
the outcomes from those
that research as well and that's really
important as i'll show on the next slide
is if you have a critical mass of
individuals with similar norms
stereotypes biases or beliefs
that that can actually shift a field in
a certain direction
and be more exclusionary so an example
of that is this is the work of londo
shebinger
in stanford university this is a great
website called gendered innovations
where she looks at case studies around
sex and gender analysis
mostly in health and medicine and
engineering so this left hand side is a
case study that she's developed around
craft chest dummies
so crash test dummies are usually
modeled on are always modeled on the
male body
what that means is all of the crash
testing the sun and all of the kind of
safety measures that are taken
are based on the male body but what that
means is if you have a pregnant women
those seat belts and the and the airbags
are are
actually detrimental to a pregnant woman
so you have higher fatality from
pregnant women and crash because they
just haven't been considered in design
and that may be because most of the
engineering's could have been men and
couldn't have considered the different
repercussions
a second really poignant example i think
is the heart disease in women
the white male body is taken as standard
for both
symptoms and treatments for heart attack
symptoms what that means is
women experience heart attacks very
differently and the treatment needs to
be different at times so
women actually die of heart attacks more
commonly than men do
because they're not even realizing that
they're having a heart attack
so again these norms and and maybe
critical masses of of researchers
individuals assuming the white male body
as the norm
has has had some serious repercussions
societally and in design of health and
medicine interventions
so what does that mean for gender and
agriculture research and development
the last concept i'm going to introduce
is what's called gender-based
constraints and these are really
important for agriculture because
everything we've talked about is there
are different restrictions on men and
women's assets to resources and
opportunities
what these culminate to are the the
gender-based constraints so how they're
constrained in
in interacting with agricultural
opportunities for example
for a small holder in in any setting
globally
small land sizes are an issue generally
you have limited range of finance and
credit options you may have limited
access to markets or productivity
but if you look at gender-based
constraints specifically
there may be laws or customs that
specifically restrict women's
land ownership you may have bank
policies that require married women to
plain their husbands signatures and i
recently learned that this was true
until 1996 in australia for example so
these are very pervasive and social
norms that limit women's networking
abilities to even
access information and that they
are they don't enjoy the same
distribution of household income and
that the benefits from agriculturally
based livelihoods may be different from
men and women even within the same
household
so all of this kind of culminates into
what's described as the gender gap and
these are
fao put these global numbers together
about five six years ago
and what you find is in plots managed by
men versus plots managed by women
there's 20 to 30 percent yield gap
same crop same regions and and if you
look at land holding
globally women own just a fraction of
all agriculturally productive land
they enjoy fewer years of formal
education less access to finances and
credit
and as well as fertilizers and seeds and
inputs
so the bottom line really is gender
determines everything a farmer has the
right to access
land labor inputs information and women
and growth specifically face systematic
barriers to only
owning and managing farms and the
solution to this
and and basically in the the spheres of
agriculture research for development are
really seen in two different but
overlapping ways of describing the
problem
one is the effectiveness argument which
means by including women and really
catering to their needs that you could
have
more adopted and effective interventions
but the flip side of that is also
recognizing that it is the right thing
to do it is the just thing to do
to really try to reduce and turn around
social inequalities historically which
have excluded women and girls from
equivalent life outcomes
so at this point in my talk usually i
have people ask me what does this have
to do at all with plant breeding
and i'll go into a few different ways
that the problem has been described
more recently personally i think plant
breeding should be more about people
than plants
because i think the people are the one
growing the plants and they have a lot
to say about how we should be designing
the varieties
when you look across a recent review
about two years ago and this is again
for public sector breeding pro
international agricultural breeding
programs
most of these programs define breeding
objectives through expert input
what does that mean breeders talking to
breeders breeders talking to key
stakeholders but not really having those
feedback loops between the communities
that are adopting the varieties and the
breeding priority setting
there's a tension between geography and
demography
so there's been work by past past
breeders and researchers for example ava
who was featured again a few weeks ago
but also bettina hossman looking at
redefining a target environment
to not just be natural quote unquote but
also socioeconomic can we kind of do g
by e by m by
social context so there's a lot of
complexity here but it's really
important
and a recent review showed that if you
look at the gender
gender balance of traits across multiple
crops that you see that the traits
follow gender divisions of labor and
market access so again
it's really important to understand who
is growing and interacting with the
crops because
that experience is shaping is is the
traits that they're preferring
and the last point i think is really
important because it is a decision
it's a power decision so who is deciding
what's being prioritized for whom
when and how is i think a really
pertinent question
so related to that last one uh if you
may know that we have an innovation lab
for crop improvement that i got granted
last year and i served as the associate
director but also a lead for a work
package called priority setting
i co-lead this with miguel gomez at
dyson his students sergio and also
elizabeth carner who's a postdoc that i
work with here
so we're really trying to to flip the
paradigm a little bit and be more
specific with the programs we work with
to articulate their intended impact so
not just general in terms of disease
resistance but really
trying to nail down exactly who they're
looking to
impact and how and that that intended
impact
would feed back to the prioritization
and product development so it's kind of
the seamless pathway
and we're looking at different levels of
prioritization for example prioritizing
problems what issues are more important
than others and what is that and
how is that importance placed based on
what and is it an issue that's solvable
why breeding first of all
and also prioritizing solutions which
alternatives for example different
product profiles or different
paths or breeding pipelines could have
greater impact
for the intended beneficiaries what is
that impact and how is it measured
so we're really thinking at this as a
very broad levels and
we're not only bringing in gender and
youth research but thinking about
nutrition research resilience and market
information
and the big picture is really how do you
distill all of that which is mostly
social science
into breeding priorities
the second big movement in this area i
would say has come from what's called
the gender breeding initiative and this
is led by the
rtb crp of the cg that's a lot of
acronyms but
for those of you related this is the
root and tuber banana coordinated
research program of the cg
and this is a group of us of gender
researchers breeders
but social scientists and many different
workshops we've had in discussions to
really
develop accessible and simple
communications
products to for the community to
understand what does it mean to be
gender responsive in breeding
so just central tenets is knowing when
and where women are important
beneficiaries and knowing how to engage
them
anticipating how design decision
decisions can impact women and be
impacted by their roles
and being intentional in designing
breeding objectives and products
for women and girls and lastly being
accountable so making sure as we're
measuring the success of these breeding
programs that we're doing so with an
intention to have positive
impact on women and girls so we've
developed some from frameworks around
this looking at the breeding cycle
looking at decision points around the
breeding cycle where are decisions that
need to be made
and how can we have intentional gender
responsive results from those decisions
so if you're interested
if you just google gender breeding
initiative all this material will come
up
but i just want to draw your attention
to this slide because i think it's
important
sometimes as plant breeders i hear i
hear claims that that this is out of my
space i can't influence social dynamics
i can only breed varieties and i think
these case studies that we put together
really illustrate that that's not
necessarily true so
three examples i want to draw your
attention to the first is maize
in china and in this particular case
inclusion of women in participatory
breeding
really expanded their horizon and
enlarged their network
so it wasn't just they act the fact that
they were included but that had a
positive
outcome in their networks and their
social networks which is
a good thing the second case is from
frederictonde and eva weltzin again in
sorghum in mali
that is as they engage women in seed
production
activities at village cooperative levels
they saw that women's preferred
varieties were being included more often
when women were included in those
processes
but again the flip side is that the act
of inclusion that women were now
engaged in seed production meant that
they could diversify their economic
activities
and the last is is from barley in syria
from alessandra gali
looking at just again the simple
inclusion of women and participatory
breeding activities
led them to be recognized as farmers and
this is a systematic problem that
women's
labor and inputs into agriculture
production are not recognized or remain
invisible
so these are all very positive potential
life outcomes just by
simple inclusion and and kind of
participation of women in breeding
activities
a third framework i want to draw your
attention to because i think you may
have run into it is we're seeing a lot
of the excellence in breeding platform
uh overhauls of the cg visions for
breeding so what this means is
the eib is really bringing a more
market-based or
industry model to cg breeding programs
and the really
heart of that is knowing who and what
you're breeding for so this is
a kind of again shift in terms of
starting with the clients and the
and the consumers and the users and
working back to breeding priority
settings so this has been a
a big shift in the cg over the last
couple years
this slide is from peter coldrick who's
working with eib right now to put
together the new
tools for the eib on market segmentation
product concept development and product
profile development
and we've been working with him through
the leadership of vivienne pallar at sip
who also leads the gender breeding
initiative
and this is kind of what was originally
planned as you look at the
obviously biological regional
environmental variability you look at
the value chain that that crop in that
region
is being funneled towards and then you
kind of define a market segment that
leads to a product concept that leads to
a product profile
so what we've done as a group is is
pushed back on this a little bit and
said
where does the kind of social fabric
come in how do you define your consumers
and how do you integrate this into the
the current model
and we've done that through adding the
square that we're
we're going to have a feedback session
with them so this is not final but this
is our proposed kind of
integration is adding a customer profile
that really defines the social
characteristics of the potential
customers
and including the social differences and
how they would be potentially
differentially
impacted or benefiting from the
different product concepts
and and vivi and jackie ashby together
have put together different tools again
to integrate into the more
eib model as you develop a product
profile
they've developed this what's called a
product profile tool which you apply to
existing product profiles to query each
trait to see
are there potential increases in
drudgery displacement of activities for
women or decreasing control of benefits
and if so this goes into this left-hand
bucket to say we should weight these
traits negatively so
so not including them would be ideal
because they may have a potential harm
for women and girls and this right-hand
side is if you look trait by trait
is there evidence of a reduction of
drudgery or more income generation or
enhancement of women's roles in that
crop
that those traits could be weighted more
positively and included in the product
profile so this has been tested now is
being tested now on
four different systems around bean
cassava sweet potato
and wheat just to see if this tool is
working on existing product profiles
there's a lot of exciting stuff going on
there
and i just want to end this this section
in terms of framing saying that the
biggest problem i think we face in this
space is that there's a lack of evidence
what does that mean that a lot of times
i get the ask the question
so what is can you point me to an
example
where there's been a variety that's been
that has been developed
that has positive impact on women and
girls and the answer to that is there is
no such variety there's there's some
evidence of negative impacts but i'll
speak to two studies recently that
really illustrate this that
we i was involved in a review of the
root tuber banana
consumer preferences and the drivers of
adoption so there were three hypotheses
that consumer traits were driving
adoption lack of
insufficient attention to gender was
negatively impacting adoption
and so the first hypothesis was found to
be true based on the evidence that the
consumer traits that were being
when consumer traits were included you
had higher adoption but the second
hypothesis to be able to say
because we're not paying attention to
gender there's a penalty on adoption
there wasn't enough studies to even say
yea your name so we it was inclusive
and the second piece here is in a
scoping study which is kind of a
systematic review that we did around 200
papers in depth looking at
how the adoption of climate resilient
varieties were impacting resilience for
communities so i was looking at the
social differences and looking to see if
there was enough evidence to say
that sex or gender were really impacting
the adoption of these varieties and what
we found was either
there was no sex desegregation of data
or where there were
there were very few women who were
involved so we couldn't make any
claims around that either again there
was this big gap in evidence and lack of
studies
so in this last kind of quarter of the
talk i'd like to give some examples so
what does this all mean and how does
this operationally look like in an
ongoing research project
the subject of studies what's called the
next gen cassava project you may have
heard this by now but
um it's a large project gates foundation
and diffid funded we're in our
seventh or eighth year at this point um
and i lead what's called the survey
division under next-gen cassava so i'll
give you some examples of how we've
approached this problem
so the overall aim of the survey
division is to have
really actionable breeding targets that
meet diversity and demand so
the actionable breeding targets is the
hard part i have to say
this in three different different ways
sorry there's some females on
three different the three different
streams of work and the first is what
is called trait descriptors what that
means is we've done a lot of work
both with next-gen cassava in
collaboration with other
programs such as rtb foods which is a
large research project i'll talk about
in a minute
to really go out and ask consumers
processors and farmers
what are the ideal characteristics that
they're looking for in an ideal cassava
variety so this is really asking what
are you looking for
and it's really open very qualitative
just to understand the words that
respondents are using and seeing if
those correlate to any traits that can
be bred for
the second kind of quadrant here is
around typologies and economic values
and looking at okay now that we know
which
characteristics respondents are looking
for can we take those
and really understand doing choice
experimentation
how relatively important these are and
develop some typologies but also
economic values and
and i'm laboring here the countries that
this work is taking place in
and we're also looking at using
household surveys to complement
not only the choices that respondents
are making but how that relates
to their demographic information so
there are specific drivers of those
choices that we can explain
with different individual social
identities
and the last part is is the on-farm
performance so
we're using a method called tricot which
i'll explain a little bit later but the
idea here is that in these first two
the top quadrants what we're asking is
explicit
or or explicit kind of articulation of
the desired traits and the rankings of
those
but what we see is sometimes implicit
choices don't really follow those
explicit articulations so what we're
trying to do here is triangulate the
explicit articulation of desired traits
and the relative ranks and weights of
those with the choices that are made by
by the very same individuals because the
same individuals will be undergoing all
of these different methods
that on farm we look to see if that
correlates or if that really
is in line with the choices that farmers
are making with varieties
so looking at the first quadrant or the
trait descriptors this is work we did in
the
first phase of nextgen that we looked at
kind of
broad brush gendered use and trait
differences and gender roles for cassava
in nigeria and
what we see and we knew this
historically that women really dominate
cassava processing and marketing of
processed products in nigeria that's a
given
they provide labor for processing as
well as production so that's kind of
their gender role
what we see is when we look at traits
articulated to be important by men and
women
there are some commonalities in traits
but then there are some traits that are
really
different for example women were
prioritizing cooking and processing
traits
which makes sense because that's their
role because they're more involved in
cassava processing
so that kind of lays the groundwork for
cassava in nigeria
but i think this left-hand figure really
shows the interesting part about
intersectionality
if you look at this right-hand side when
we look at all men and women across
nigeria from the
our kind of surveys if you look at how
people or men and women are saying their
household use of cassava you see that
that women
or men will more often mention that
they're selling fresh fruits of cassava
whereas women may more often be
mentioning their processing and selling
the process
product so if we take this at face value
we can say that generally
women men are selling fresh whereas
women are processing and selling
but what we then did is we broke this
down and disaggregated by region in
addition to sex and what you see is that
effect is really coming from the
southwest of nigeria
whereas in the southeast the pitcher is
very different and you can explain this
because in the southeast women are
called cassava queens so they're very
involved in marketing of cassava in any
form
whereas in the southwest the men and
women are engaging in cassava markets
differently
so we can't make broad brush
generalizations for the whole country so
that was kind of the lesson learned
there
feeding on from that recently over the
last three years
and this new project called rtb foods
working with
gender experts as well as food
scientists and breeders we've developed
kind of
scaled out this idea in terms of how do
you
kind of get to the bottom of some of
these consumer and consumption traits
and do that across multiple root tuber
and banana
to bring banana varieties across
sub-saharan africa so what we've done is
this is
again been recently published if you
want to look it up but it's a multi-step
interdisciplinary method
and it's very participatory so a lot of
the work is happening with
processors and consumers of the of these
crops and there's about 13 different
food products around 10 different
countries
so if you look at the data emerging from
that in terms of the gender analysis
it's kind of impossible to ignore the
role of women
across all of the rtb procs crops in
terms of
processing selling and food preparation
so
really they are the key informants in
that role so consultation with women
across
all the value chains for most of these
products is
really important because they hold
really unique and individual knowledge
and the type of extent of gender
differences and preferences was very
different by country and product so we
couldn't again
generalize some of this that we had to
look at case by case to really draw
out the differences and this is work
that's currently led by laura forsythe
that we're looking to publish this this
comparative study around the different
rtb crops across sub-saharan africa
so next moving into this left hand
an idea of the different words and the
scriptures for characteristics of the
ideal varieties of these different root
and tubers especially cassava for for
this work
uh is now understanding okay there may
be a list of 20 different traits how
important are these traits to whom
so we're using a method called 1000
minds which is a
choice experimentation based methods
it's been used in marketing for
for just different products and it's
been applied to animal breeding and
it's the the abacus bio is our partner
there and we're applying it to crops
across multiple crops right now and
cassava is one of the first use studies
so the idea really here is first you try
to get a list a short list of traits
that you want to work with then you have
to define the units of those traits and
the change in units as you're
kind of asking respondents to trade off
different scenarios
what that means is you can have when you
ask a respondent would you like
kind of 25 percent more roots versus
10 percent less disease resist or less
infection so you kind of ask respondents
to trade off different scenarios and do
that over and over again with
the trait units changing you know up or
down depending on the first decision
made
what that really does is it kind of
gives you an ultimate rank of the traits
for all the respondents but it also
gives you economic weights because you
you look at the economic value you do a
lot of baseline work
through focus groups and interviews to
understand the economic values of each
of the traits
this is work that at least foreign
cassava is driven by irati balagun in
nigeria and that's the results that i'll
be referring to
so when you look at all of the
respondents in nigeria and we had about
a thousand odd respondents that we we
tried this method with in nigeria
when you look at the big picture and
step back you see that there are three
broad categories
respondents that care about quality so
these are the traits around
gary which is the major product of of
cassava in nigeria
and there are the respondents who care
more about output so how much absolute
output you're getting in terms of yield
root size dry matter content and then
there are respondents who are caring
more about survival so disease
resistance and storability were
being more highly ranked in those in
those groups
so what's interesting is if you take
these three groups now and look at the
demography again the the kind of who are
is making these choices and who's
represented in these three different
groups you see that women are over
represented in the quality group and
that's not surprising again because
their role in cassava processing they're
probably
more involved in quality at the
interfacing with the quality than the
manor
but again the intersectionalities it
depends on who you are along the value
chain
also has significant impacts on which
group you're falling into
and also the age matters as does region
and access to improved varieties so it's
not a simple picture to be able to say
everyone falls in this group depending
on if they're this or that that we
really have a lot of different variables
that we're looking at that are driving
these choices
so kind of the next phase of this work
that ireti is digging into right now is
now as we said looking at men and women
more broadly is interesting because we
don't want to develop one type apology
for everyone in nigeria but what happens
if we disaggregate
the responses by sex by region by value
chain rule do we see differences
so does that pca look different if we
have women versus men
does it look different if we have
different regions so she's working
through that now and i think it's really
interesting to see if those
typologies hold another thing that's
really really exciting and novel for
this method
is merging this data with the roma
status aromas is a household survey but
what it does is it generates poverty
indicators
for individuals and also food security
indicators for individuals what that
means is you can actually place an
individual
in a quantile for poverty or food
security
what that means is if you relate these
two data sets to one another you can
actually start saying
women in the southeast of nigeria in the
in the slowest quantile for poverty
this is what their typology looks like
so that
at each step of this desegregation
obviously you lose a lot of power but we
have the data set to be able to play
around with this and really refine this
method which is
very very exciting
what also we're innovating on on this
1000 minds and this is work led by
olamide ola khan at iita nigeria
tessie modu at nrcri and elizabeth
garner is a postdoc working with me at
cornell
they're looking at how we apply 1000
minds and what that means from an
inter-household perspective
so in practice usually you would talk to
one member of the household and that
member of the household traditionally
for surveys
is chosen as being the head of household
and usually the factor that's a man
so there's a lot of push in economic
literature to say we need to be
intentional about
speaking to not just women who are heads
of household but spouses of household
heads
so how do how do the the spouses the
husband and wife relate to another and
responding to surveys so we've done this
with 1000 minds we've interviewed the
husband
we've interviewed the wife in about 360
households and we've interviewed the
couple
so what that means is we have responses
from the husband the wife
and a negotiated couple's interview and
the reason why we wanted to do is see if
there are any shifts
so if you have individual responses of a
negotiated response
what does the negotiated response look
like does it look more like the man's
response would look more like the
women's response and what does that mean
for the method
what we saw is sure enough there are
individually
significantly different rankings for
profitability and maturity that men were
preferring and product quality again
that women were preferring
kind of we already know that but then
when you come together as a couple if
you listen to these transcripts you hear
the men
doing a lot more of the speaking so our
assumption was
that the negotiated response would look
more like the men's response
but what we really found is that that's
not true so in the negotiation
women's response the couple response is
more towards whoever feels more strongly
so their profitability and maturity if
it was lower rank for women in the
individual
in the couple's response that was kind
of shifted upwards because the men felt
strongly about that and vice versa
so it was kind of an equal shift which
was really interesting
so the last part is this on-farm
performance trials just to kind of
triangulate these articulations of
preference
with choices made on farm with varieties
we've decided to adopt this on-farm
trial method called tricot some of you
may have heard of this
and this is jacob van etten this is his
paper from 2017 describing tricot
and he really frames it as a problem of
of the quote-unquote classic way of
doing on-farm trials is their high costs
they have limited scale
the data quality may be low and you may
get limited learning so he's kind of
brought in the citizen science approach
saying you know this is a turn of the
century this experiment if you weigh a
bull versus you ask 800
individuals to guess the weight of the
bully you may arrive at the same
estimation
so the solution offered by tricot is
really that
you take your you really step back as a
researcher
and you give farmers varieties and the
farmers manage
those trials and they're farmer leads
who collect the data not researchers
and the participation itself is the main
incentive and the
participants are counterparts in the
research so when you kind of frame this
and and do the initial initial
contact with the participants that it's
framed as being a research activity and
that as citizen scientists you know
they're co they're collaborating in this
research activity
there's very little supervision or
training that happens and you kind of
let the process
unfold the interesting parts of it i
think are that
you give three varieties per farmer
these are blind so
the the farmers don't know which
varieties they are and they only rank
for best and worse
at overall or each time point however
you choose and each farm is an
incomplete block so we had up to 30 to
50 reps
across different farmers for different
varieties depending on how you design
it and you have a sequentially balanced
design so that you make sure that you
have replication
across different regions for example
depending on different product uses in
different regions
and the bottom line is you really
embrace variation in the environment and
crop management
don't try to control for it
so if you're interested there's a paper
from 2019 from yuco buenos team
and pnas and they really showed how the
method played out for beans in costa
rica
for durum wheat in ethiopia and for
bread wheat in india looking at how
different varieties of different colors
or different
varieties how they were performing
across the different regions
for these three different crops
so again we try to do things a little
bit differently with tricot so
talking to yucca we try to understand
first of all
how participants were selected and if we
can do that a little bit differently
so instead of relying on village leads
or lead farmers to kind of recruit
participants we made sure that we did a
lot of groundwork through interviews and
focus groups to understand the diversity
in each of the communities that we
worked in
so we didn't only have geographically
representative sampling but we also
looked at the differences in wealth sex
age migration status religion within
each community so that
the host farmers were chosen to reflect
that diversity
and this is really important because
sometimes you just don't know who's
being selected and if we're not
intentional we may be missing out on key
insights
from marginalized populations that
wouldn't have been included if the
choice were random
we also again had because the same
individuals who were participating in
tricot were also answering the 1000 mind
surveys we have this really
kind of in-depth understanding of of
their their
social identities but also their
demographics and their typologies of
what we did was maybe having too much
data that we didn't have
we had multiple time points and then
each time put multiple
traits that we were ranking best and
worse for so we end up with really
a large and complex data set
so this is ongoing and the data is being
analyzed by samuel and vuca
nrcra in nigeria stephen ongodubo in in
uganda and kawai who works with jacob to
help kind of
help us analyze these large data sets
and i'll be showing very first
pass data for mostly first and third
month because the trials just concluded
this summer so we're still
working through the data and this is
kind of what you see you get net
favorability scores for varieties and
and you see
how those play out over time so for
example if we
competitiveness is if a variety is
performing very well in a certain time
point
does that play out across time does that
explain
overall selection for example because at
each time point we have
trait rankings but we have overall
rankings as well
so this is kind of what you the data
looks like and we also look at if there
are correlations between for example
this is for
cooking quality for boiled cassava in
uganda
if any of the individual traits are kind
of explaining that overall performance
and we're seeing that be very variable
across time points
but in terms of bringing in some some
disaggregation by sex
uh it's a little bit more difficult so
we have to work with jakob and his team
to tease out some of these effects but
what kawei has done is actually look
and see at least to segregate by sex and
what we're seeing is kind of interesting
methodologically
is that women are more consistent in the
varieties that they're ranking for
individual traits at one in three months
match their overall rankings for those
same varieties so they're kind of more
consistent
in ranking the varieties
and the last part of this is as of
course we have on-farm trials we don't
want the process to be extractive and we
want to give feedback to communities and
continuously engage with them because
we'll also have another round of these
trials next year
so we're right now developing and this
is work led by olamida
again in bella abalore in iita in
nigeria trying to develop
these feedback guides for lead farmers
and for
for focus group facilitators to really
understand how do we give feedback to
the farmers who participate and how do
we engage them to
to validate or to give or give insights
on what the findings that we're bringing
back to them
so we have about 10 participants and the
presents the results will be presented
both
visually and orally and the participants
of course are given an opportunity to
exchange planting materials and
experiences through these events
the idea is to really create inclusive
and safe feedback platforms for
discussions to see if the results really
reflect
participants experiences and to maybe
counter balance leader effects because
every 10 farmer
is the data is managed by one lead
farmer per every 10 farmer
so we want to make sure that there are
no leader effects in in the data that
we're getting
and that the participants really feel
contribution to the process
and the outcome so there's an
opportunity to feedback and alter the
outcomes
and this really strengthens
relationships and trust for the next
phases of tricots that will be planted
in
april may
so again at the end of it as i come to
the conclusion how do we make sense of
all of this
and as i was thinking this through i
thought there are two levels to really
thinking about
one is really systems level so we know
that there are pervasive gender
issues in agriculture globally and that
these are reflected in plant breeding
and if we want to address the needs of
women and girls intentionally in crop
improvement we really need to take a
step back and look at our priorities our
power and processes and current breeding
systems
and that we really need to invest more
in gender focused studies to help fill
some of the evidence
gaps that i was alluding to earlier and
i think
interdisciplinary teams are absolutely
non-negotiable to be able to breed for
intentional social impact and that some
of the methods that
you use would have to be themselves
interdisciplinary
because who you ask and how makes all
the difference to the information that
you're getting
and i would say the biggest challenge we
currently face and especially the next
gen work over the next year
is making sense of these multiple data
streams to really distill
down into actionable breeding targets
and i think that in itself is going to
be
a significant task that we may again
have to
innovate around a little bit
and i think as individuals especially in
this plant breeding seminars for
students as well is to understand that
as researchers we all carry internalized
biases stereotypes and positions
and whether we realize it or not these
implicitly drive our work so
kind of being aware of that i think is
really important as we try to shift the
narrative to be more inclusive and to be
more impactful in our plant breeding
work
and that challenging our assumptions and
working with people outside of our
comfort zone is really half the battle
because it is not easy to have these
conversations
and i would just like to make the call
for often i hear it's just too complex
that the social context is too complex
we can't handle it
but i'd like to just make a call to say
we should try to embrace the social
complexity as much as we embrace and
embrace the genetic complexity in
breeding and try to understand it and
model it and respond to it to be more
effective in our breeding programs
so with that i'll uh say thank you and
start taking questions and say that
there are probably
far too many people to think on one
slide but i want to really say
margaret mangani and her team at makari
for doing a lot of the gender training
around
agriculture research and plant breeding
more specifically
the next-gen cassava teams in nigeria
and our cri
at iata at nacre in uganda
and also tari in tanzania for doing a
lot of the field work and generating
this this huge amount of data
and as we set out for the new feed the
future innovation lab for crop
improvement to miguel elizabeth and
sergio for sitting together and trying
to understand this big problem and how
we can build frameworks that are
consistently gathering evidence for
informed decisions
uh so with that i'll thank you and take
questions
can i ask a question
i'm moderating or oh sorry i was sorry i
was i just wanted to
i'm sorry i did was i on me that whole
time yes
oh i'm really sorry oh i'm just on
display as of like
for totally uncomfortable sorry before
before i hand the floor to you let me
just say that i
i was trying to thank you for your proud
profoundly thoughtful and
thought-provoking
presentation and the way that you
brought these issues of diversity equity
inclusion i think are on on top of mind
for
a lot of people with uh black lives
matter moment
but and more and more specifically
bringing them to the
uh bringing out this range of ethical
but also very very practical
ways in which uh gender considerations
are important in plant breeding and
um i i did i wanted to just just thank
you for bringing that the rich
experience from
the gender responsive researchers
equipped for a transformation project
great
and next-gen cassava and also the feed
the future lab for club improvement and
also the
root to banana work from the cg
you've been through your your
international activities you brought
this wealth of experiences
and also evidence for a new and exciting
toolkit
that is leading to these these really
powerful findings
so i wanted the question i want upon the
table
is what do you see as the implications
for
the train that we as a as a section
bring to
plant breeders and you know also to you
know plant scientists more generally
in steps like can you comment on how you
see
like how we should think about
confronting our own curriculum and
opening up this
box more this toolkit that you've
highlighted here how should we be
looking at our curriculum our training
process
to do better at both the ethical and
practical aspects that you have so
brilliantly highlighted thank you
rebecca i think that's such a great
question
and one thing i have to say to start off
is i think makada university does a
better job than we do
and for me it's been such an inspiration
to watch how
you know gender and social difference
issues are really
spread across a lot of the curriculum
it's kind of a non-negotiable and i look
at that and i think why aren't we doing
that
and i think it's not just about gender
in our case but
it is about race it is about systematic
racism it's about representation
if you've any been to these
biodiversified workshop for example
querying curriculum and looking at it
with a critical angle to say
who's being represented and heard and
how and why
is something i really think we have to
do for all of sips but maybe for plant
breeding we can start with kind of a
smaller unit
and looking at our curriculum with that
lens on and seeing
what are some of the concepts and
assumptions and representation that's
coming through our curriculum and is
that how
it should be coming through so i think
it's really important i think we can
also have
targeted modules or courses looking at
these issues because
what a lot of times i get asked is what
does this look like domestically
and you probably won't be very surprised
that women and underrepresented
minorities in the u.s have exactly the
same problems that i'm talking about
lack of access to finances smaller land
holdings lower profitability
lack of access to resources and networks
so it's not an international problem and
i think that needs to come a little bit
more to the fore as we think about how
we're doing our work so
i think two sides one just looking at
the existing curriculum and two
generating new curriculum to
specifically address
diversity and inclusion in all of the
work that we do would be
ideal
over to you uh yeah i had essentially
the same question as you did rebecca
my i was starting from the perspective
of
unless i'm mistaken within plant
breeding genetics we don't have any
course
that would hand over the the knowledge
and expertise that you
just demonstrated to our students and
how much of a problem is that obviously
it's a big problem
although you framed it much more
as as wanting to have it pervade the
whole curriculum as opposed to
uh a single course that would that would
be about
you know your your three slices of the
pie that you showed
over your talk but anyway if you have
any comment go for it
yeah okay so two thoughts i think both
are needed because
what you see a lot as well is quote
unquote siloing of gender research
and you see that internationally a lot
there's a gender expert or a gender
researcher and they're kind of in their
own corner and they're fighting their
own battles and
you know the larger teams around plant
breeding and agronomy are kind of
hearing it but not really
completely taking everything on board i
would like to avoid that happening in
the curriculum where you have like the
diversity course and then everything
else
right so i think we need to have those
specific courses but we also need to
look at the full curriculum so i think
both of those are needed for different
reasons
um i'm just gonna call nick would you
mind articulating your question or do
you want me to read it
oh i was just uh thanks for the talk
um i was just interested in like
how long it i mean because improving for
agronomic trait you know can take
several years and just wondering if you
see improving for these traits to be
faster or slower
that's a great question um there is
an assumption and i like to flag
assumptions but there are assumptions
that it's
much more costly to do this kind of work
and
i'd like to challenge that a little bit
because i think the opportunity cost i
mean
the the potential flip side of it is
we're completely missing our targets so
what's the cost of developing something
that's not being adopted
versus taking a little bit more time and
more upfront investment
to presumably develops things that will
be adopted more readily again that's a
logical leap
but i don't really have a dollar value
attached to saying this
kind of research versus this but what we
are doing is looking at costing all the
models in nextgen all the methods that
we're using
to see what is the cost to the breeding
program because ultimately we want these
methods to be sustainable and applicable
right we can't say we're going to do
tri-cot forever
the grant ends what happens is this
really a method that is cost effective
and is the information coming out
interesting enough for that investment
so we are modeling that within nixon or
we intend to at least
so i don't have the answer broadly but i
think within
a project we can start looking at that
very question
and can ed do you want to do you want to
speak your question
um ed's asking how to make the social
side hi through but over to you anton
yeah i mean i guess the the question i
have i
agree these are incredibly complex
systems just like genetics is and we
need to
embrace that complexity but i would all
you know part of the way we've made
progress in genetics is having been able
to scale and get enough data to deal
with it
and that we see that social manipulation
side
working in like how google does ads or
facebook
but those are you know not necessarily
for positive goals
how do we scale this type of
thing for positive goals
so we can you know you have enough
observations in each one of these
categories to make statements
yeah how do you get a half a million
observations um
two sides to the answer to that question
is
if you look at the social science and i
can't speak for all social scientists
because i'm not one
but what i've understand from a lot of
the work is there's
quantitative social science and there's
qualitative social science and then
there's
there's mixed methods or
interdisciplinary social science right
so
the numbers are really important for the
quantitative work which means you know
you want the hundreds and the thousands
to be able to have enough power to make
inferences on a quantitative
hypothesis that you're trying to answer
so there you can get more numbers you
can have
quote unquote more high throughput if
you have a survey that you massively
roll out but the really really
interesting information i think comes
from coupling that with
qualitative work which shouldn't be
scaled arguably because it is very
contextual and it's very
it's it's a personal case study for
example or it's it's not trying to
generalize it's trying to understand
so as we get some of the numbers and you
know i think google probably does the
same in
terms of the numbers you also need some
more qualitative information
for the house and the wise so i think we
shouldn't necessarily try to scale
all of the social science side we can
try getting more numbers like with the
1000 minds
the more respondents we have the better
but then if you do the interviews and do
the more qualitative work and do more
on-farm trials
maybe we don't try to scale that as much
but we try to go deeper and try to
couple those two i think that's where we
need a little more thought
is how those two come together and what
it means for breeding so
um i think like the 1000 minds is a good
example of what you're saying is because
it's coming from marketing it's coming
from that world
it's just being adapted to to kind of
crop improvement
so there are opportunities to adopt but
not
exclude some of the qualitative work
that's really important
and um martin want to go ahead with your
questions about tri-cut
sure um and i kind of think they they
fit right in with what um
ed and nick were asking too um i i was
wondering about
i i do think that iterating the tricot
or doing more tricot
uh which kind of scaling up to
continuously collect data
are kind of interesting so i was
wondering uh if you have plans to
to like do another round maybe with the
same farmers and whether you could
you were saying at the end of your talk
about um how can we provide them
feedback
can we provide them new varieties to
test
and see how their their rankings their
uh
so yeah uh that is my question
thank you martin um so we had planned in
nigeria to
to replicate the tricot twice so with
the same farmers and switching out i
think the bottom five percent or ten
percent of varieties which were very
consistently performing
badly so we can integrate a little more
of the other next-gen varieties that are
coming through the pipeline so
with minimal tweaking we were going to
kind of replicate the same
exact formulas and the the the same
system
so we will do that but what i think is a
little bit testament to the interest for
this method in uganda
it surprised me that the breeding
program there said we also want to
repeat this because we think it's really
interesting
so i think there may be hope for that
throughput question of
of if the breeding program see enough
value in this this could be a
and this is where we we're having
conversations with people like ismail
robbie on the project saying
how often do you need to run these kind
of on-farm trials do they need to happen
every year every three years every five
years
what makes sense with what kind of
regularity do you need to have this
touching base
with with individuals and who do you
work with
do you work with the same farmer so what
you see with eva's work for example in
sorghum and mali is they had a group of
farmers that they interacted with over
decades and that longitudinal deep
relationship was really important
in getting kind of those the deeper
feedback and the opening up
and the trust building so there's
argument for kind of scaling out to more
individuals to getting more data points
versus kind of
having the same individuals be your
citizen science
group to give regular feedback i think
that's something that
we don't have an answer to right now
because we're just trying it but there
is definitely at least two rounds that
we'll get out of nextgen and then
maybe beyond hopefully
and uh elizabeth you had asked um i mean
you had mentioned that
the point that plant breeders can make
common cause with other
units for example at cornell um do you
want to
enlarge on that
thank you rebecca yeah i just wanted to
build from what holly was already
talking about and
her emphasis i really appreciate as a
rural sociologist and feminist scholar
about emphasizing interdisciplinary work
and really building from the expertise
that already exists and so
especially thinking about curricula and
who to partner with
that at least from my perspective like i
don't feel like
these issues need to be all solved by
plant breeders because there are so many
of us already doing
a lot of this work and addressing some
of these complexities
and with some of the background but how
important it is to partner and build
from the resources that already exist so
even with
curricular development maybe it's not
just
designing a unique course for plant
breeders
but really thinking about what resources
already exist at cornell
and it's also a way to highlight and
integrate the work
of scholars who sometimes get overlooked
or don't have the same kind of funding
that plant breeders might have for
example so thank you
and thanks holly great talk elizabeth is
live in here i mentioned her several
times in the talk but
but i think it's interesting like
elizabeth's saying is we often have
these conversations between us coming
from very different angles and
it's really interesting exercise and i i
really agree with you that
more systematic linking with fgss or
africana would be very interesting i
think for us as a unit
and i think your the work that you
presented really highlights not only the
need to have different sorts of scholars
and scholarship
in the mix but also different kinds of
um organizations out there in the world
that just like in order to pull off a
good
tri-cut approach i i expect it would be
helpful to have
strong relations with community-based
organizations that can
support the farmers to like have a
deeper experience through the work
and to participate at a more profound
level not just testing out three things
so
um anyway holly i think we're running
out of time here and again i would like
to really thank you so much for a
fabulous talk
and bringing that breadth of fantastic
experience that you have
to this um dimension of of crop
improvement that you know again
uh can improve the the way that the
our our field benefits other people and
the way that we we also benefit from
better engagement in terms of getting
our job done so thanks so much holly
really fantastic talk and i really
appreciate it very much i hope we can
continue this conversation about how to
bring these messages into our training
and practice thank you rebecca for the
invitation and thank you for your time
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu